hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
perennial problems dealing with
friendship that Marcus Tullius Cicero
talks about in his work on friendship is
this dynamic and perhaps even for many
people dilemma should you favor old
friends or should you favor new friends
and he doesn't talk at great length
about this but it's it's worth
reflecting why this is viewed as a
problem in the first place and it was
just as much of a problem in Cicero's
own day and time as it remains for us
and time is is really part of the
problem I mean we we think about old and
new those are temporal words right the
friends who you've had for a very long
time perhaps you met in childhood or in
school together went through some sort
of thing they could be family members
who you you know been in touch with your
entire life right and then we've got new
friends something new is happening a
friendship a locus of affection and
goodwill an agreement is blossoming into
a relationship and that's happening now
or you know just happened in the near
past compared to the friendships that
you've had that grew in the past
have been going along for quite some
time so we've got that sort of sense but
I also mean another sense in which time
is a major factor friendship is a
challenge in part because time is
limited for all of us we all get exactly
the same 24 hours as everybody else and
we can find ways to you know multiply
our time or trying to save our time all
sorts of life hacks and management
things but you really when it comes down
to it you still only get those 24 hours
and you hopefully spend about you know
seven to eight of them sleeping so you
know there's all sorts of other things
do you have enough time to do justice to
both of these kinds of friendships the
new friendships which you know demand
quite a bit of time upfront because you
don't actually know the person yet and
you're in that phase of learning about
them and then learning about you and
doing a lot of things together or do you
devote your time to the old friendships
that do require maintenance you can't
rely on them as just sort of you know
I'll go back to it every couple years
and we'll still be friends they may have
completely changed if you've lost touch
like that or they may not have you know
it's kind of a risk so we're do you a
lot this valuable resource that you have
of time and not just time thought
affection attention so Cicero raises
this as a genuine problem should new
friends and notice that he's got this
provision here worthy of friendship not
so it's not just anybody that you claim
to be a friend or calls you a friend but
people who are actually worthy of
friendship should they be preferred to
old friends we can make this very
concrete right you have a particular day
that you have free and two people call
you up and they say hey I'm going to
have a party can you come over we'd
really like to have you here one of them
is somebody who you're in a new
relationship with that's grown
into friendship you think they're a good
person and they certainly treat you like
a good person the other is somebody who
you've known for a long time you know
that they're a good person you like them
who do you choose and do you if you're
going to say something to the friend do
you do you tell them sorry I can't go to
your party new friend because I've
already got this old friend over here
and I need to spend time with them
or do you say listen you know we can
always see each other I've got to spend
time with this person you don't mind do
you
these are the sorts of things that do
come up quite a bit in in friendships
and it can happen in you know regular
friendships that were all experienced in
it can happen in virtual relationships
as well so he point he raises this
question right and then he adds an
interesting little metaphor as we're
accustom to prefer young horses to old
ones now not too many of us have horses
right so it's a little hard to relate to
that but think about this as you prefer
your new smartphone to your old
smartphone or laptop or desktop or car
or I don't know tie alright shirt
anything any object that you might say
or if we're thinking about animals do
you prefer the the new puppy the new
kitten to your old aged dog or cat who
can't play anymore
now it gets really personal doesn't it
right and so this this young horse is
two old horses why would we prefer young
horses well the young horses you know
can can do their work better this is
kind of an instrumental way of looking
at friendship and there's also it does
capture the idea that there there's
perhaps more excitement on the side of
the new friend
as an object of our affection than there
is on the side of the old true
reliable friend who he might be passing
up so Cicero says no no no we should not
do that
and he gives several reasons why one of
them is really quite interesting he says
there should be in this translation has
no surfed it we could translate that as
surplus or overabundance or anything
like that
Sathya toss is is the word there and
that's the word that we get satiety from
when we talk about you know eating
enough food and our stomach is full and
we feel that sense of having had enough
there is just from saying there isn't
that had enough of friendship as a
matter of fact we should try to do both
at the same time no he doesn't tell us
how to juggle this but he does tell us
that we should keep our old friendships
and he suggests that we can do that
through habit we'll look at that a
little bit more and what he has to say
about that in just a bit but then he
also says that we shouldn't reject new
friendships if they offer a certain kind
of hope right they says new friendships
are not to be scorned if they offer the
hope of bearing fruit like green shoots
of corn that do not disappoint us at
harvest time many of us probably are not
gardeners I myself have grown a lot of
things in my life when he when we're
translating this is corn it doesn't
necessarily mean corn in the sense that
we Americans talk about it he's talking
about wheat or barley or anything like
that I didn't meant as a seed when we
see these these shoots arising that's
sort of like seeing a friendship that
has promise the promise of bearing fruit
that is enjoyment and the sort of
intimacy that becomes possible in
genuine friendships when we think that
that's there
we shouldn't scorn that but he says the
old friendships must preserve their own
place for the force of age and habit is
very great and he also says something
quite interesting about the horse
metaphor so if you thought that Cicero
was being a bit inhumane about horses at
this point he says even in the case of
the horse just now referred to everybody
no nothing preventing would rather use
one to which he has grown accustomed
than one that is untrained and new and
this habit is strong in the case not
only of animate but also inanimate
things since we delight even in places
the rugged and wild in which we've lived
for a fairly long time people will say
this about their hometown and somebody
else complains about it they're like you
know Milwaukee sucks and they hey who
are you to talk about that that's my
City sort of like when people complain
about our family members only we get to
say bad things about them right because
we have this familiarity we have this
this sense of affection towards them
that's built up through habit so Cicero
thinks that in some sense if we if we
work at it we can have it all that
doesn't mean that we can automatically
be friends with everybody and if we're
gonna follow out this agricultural
metaphor it's not like every single
possible shoot that's coming up we
should be like oh this is a great friend
a great friend a great friend no no we
shouldn't be doing that we would still
have to be rather selective and here
again we come to the the factor of time
he says two very interesting things
about old friendships that help to you
know stress why it is that we need to
hold on to them to inducements and both
of these do have to do with time one of
them well actually both of them are
metaphors so the first one is that old
friendships are like wine that has been
aged and because of that aging process
qualities of the wine come out that were
not immediately apparent in the earlier
stages of that wine and it becomes as he
says more pleasant more delightful so
old friendships in which this intimacy
has developed have a greater depth to
them a better bouquet right although
maybe our friends don't always smell
great it really depends on the friends
buzz of it but but you get the idea and
we could actually follow out this this
you know vintners metaphor a little bit
further the young friends are very
attractive because they're like that
fresh
young wine if you've ever had you know
for example in Portugal they have what
can be translated as green wine that's
very young it's kind of effervescent
it's got a bold you know taste to it or
if you've ever had like Nouveau
Beaujolais right you know these these
things can be quite nice but it's not
the same thing as the really well aged
Cabernet isn't which has a greater
potential you might say to to to please
so that's an interesting metaphor right
there and then he takes from Aristotle
who took it from other people as well
it's a proverb already old and
Aristotle's time that we have to eat
some measures of salt with a person
before we can actually consider them to
be a true friend and the idea here is we
need to develop intimacy one way in
which we do develop intimacy is by
living with and having meals with a
person we converse over the meals we
share the salt you know iron if
somebody's hoarding salt which was a
valuable commodity I mean I'm tell you
don't want to be friends with them right
there's stingy with the salt right or
maybe they they salt everything too much
but having that that bucket or measure
of salt together allows us to to know
that somebody really is a good friend so
what is what is Cicero's answer to this
there's good reasons to want to have old
and new friends we shouldn't just
withdraw into old friendships and be
closed off to the potentials of new
friendships at the same time we have to
keep our old friends we really ought to
do this and notice that he's not making
an argument here based on sort of duty
or obligation he's saying it's it's
better for you to keep your old
friendships that's the smart thing to do
so how is this done he doesn't actually
tell us but he is providing us with his
own viewpoint on the matter
you